hello everyone and welcome back to
Simply learns YouTube channel today we
are going to take you through an
exciting Topic in cloud computing we are
going to discuss the type of job roles
available in this field whether you are
new to the world of cloud computing or
looking to explore exciting career
opportunities you are in the right place
in this video we'll dive into four key
categories of cloud computing jobs
making them easy to understand and
packed with valuable insights but before
we begin if you enjoy watching these
videos and find them interesting then
subscribe to our YouTube channel because
we bring the best videos for you daily
also hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn do check out
the cloud architect Masters program by
simply loan this program will help you
build your AWS Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform expertise from the
ground up you'll learn to master the
architectural principles and services of
the top Cloud platforms design and
deploy highly scalable for fall tolerant
applications and develop skills to
transform yourself into an AWS and Azure
Cloud expert the program will give you
an in-depth understanding of cloud
services such as AWS cloud formation
Azure resource manager ec2 S3 Route 53
VPC asure app services gcp and many more
you'll acquire the Knowledge and Skills
for passing Cloud architect
certification such as AWS architect and
Azo architect candidates with one plus
years of work experience are preferred
to enroll in this program so check out
the link mentioned in the description
box below for more details so without
any further delay let's start this video
on types of cloud computing jobs our
first category is all about jobs related
to Major Cloud providers like AWS Amazon
web services Microsoft Azure and gcp
Google Cloud platform we have two
primary roles within this category Cloud
administrators and Cloud Architects so
let's move on and check these rules out
the first is cloud administrator
a cloud administrator is a professional
responsible for managing and overseeing
the day-to-day operations of cloud
computing environments within an
organization their primary role is to
ensure that the cloud infrastructure is
running smoothly efficiently securely
and in accordance with the
organization's needs and objectives the
roles and responsibilities of a cloud
administrator includes resource
provisioning Cloud administrators are
responsible for provisioning and
configuring Cloud resources such as
virtual machines storage data bases and
networking components they ensure that
resources are allocated appropriately
based on workload requirements Security
Management they Implement and manage
security measures within the cloud
environment this includes setting up
firewalls access controls encryption and
identify and access management policies
to protect data and resources monitoring
and
optimization Cloud administrators
continuously monitor the performance and
health of cloud services they use
monitoring tools to detect and address
issues promptly optimizing resource
utilization and ensuring High
availability backup and Disaster
Recovery they create and manage Backup
and Disaster Recovery plans to safeguard
data and applications against data loss
or system failures this involves regular
data backups and testing of recovery
procedures the last is cost management
Cloud administrators are responsible for
managing Cloud costs they monitor
resource usage identify cost saving
opportunities and adjust resource
allocation as needed to optimize
expenses finally let's go through the
career path of a cloud administrator the
career path starts from a junior Cloud
administrator entry-level position with
responsibilities under supervision
focused on learning cloud management
fundamentals then Cloud administrator
managing day-to-day Cloud operations
independently with expertise in resource
provisioning security and
troubleshooting and finally a senior
Cloud administrator assuming leadership
roles including managing complex Cloud
environments optimizing costs and
contributing to the architecture
decisions talking about the salary of a
cloud administrator according to glasso
the average salary of a cloud
administrator is
$95,400 in the United States and in
India it goes around 7ak 74,000 rupees
per year with additional cash benefits
it depends on the company you are
working for and the skills you possess
also it may worry depending on which
cloud service you have mastered moving
on to the next job role in this segment
we have a cloud architect a cloud
architect is a specialized IT
professional responsible for Designing
planning and overseeing the architecture
of cloud computing Solutions within an
organization they play a pivotal role in
translating business requirements into
technical specifications and ensuring
that the cloud infrastructure meets the
organization's goals for scalability
security performance and cost
Effectiveness so let's talk about the
roles and responsibilities of a cloud
Cloud architect solution design Cloud
Architects design cloud-based Solutions
tailored to an organization's needs they
work closely with stakeholders to
understand business requirements and
objectives and then create comprehensive
Cloud architecture plans to meet those
goals Cloud platform selection they
evaluate and recommend the appropriate
cloud service providers for example AWS
Azure or gcp and services that best
align with the organization's
requirements and budget constraints
scalability and and performance Cloud
Architects ensure that the cloud
architecture can scale to handle
increased workloads and maintain Optimal
Performance this includes designing
autoscaling mechanisms and load
balancing
strategies security they are responsible
for implementing robust security
measures including exess controls
encryption and compliance with industry
standards and regulations Cloud
Architects design security into every
layer of the cloud infrastructure the
last is cost optimization managing Cloud
cost is significant aspect of their role
they design cost efficient architectures
monitor resource usage and Implement
cost saving strategies like reserved
instances or spot instances so let's go
through the career path of a cloud
architect the career path for a cloud
architect typically follows certain
stages like Cloud Solutions architect
entry-level position where individual
starts gaining experience in Cloud
architecture and solution design then
comes Cloud architect as Cloud
Architects gain experience they take on
more complex project projects and
responsibilities often leading
architecture teams senior Cloud
Architects experienced Cloud Architects
may take on senior or lead roles guiding
architectural decisions for large scale
Crow projects principal Cloud architect
this is a senior leadership role where
individuals may act as a Chief Architect
or lead multiple architectural teams and
the last is cloud architect manager or
director in larger organizations Cloud
architect managers or directors oversee
teams of cloud Architects and have
broader responsibilities for cloud
strategy to excel this role Cloud
Architects often pursue relevant
certifications if you also want to
master the field you can consider
enrolling in our Cloud architect Masters
program so don't forget to check out the
link mentioned in the description box
below talking about the salary of a
cloud architect according to glasso the
average salary of a cloud architect is
$171,500 perm in the United States and
in India it goes around rupees 22 lakh
per year with additional cash benefits
it depends on the company you are
working for and the skills you possess
in our second category we'll talk about
Cloud devops jobs these professionals
are like the connectors between
development and operations teams
ensuring a smooth software delivery
process the job role we have in this
category is of a cloud devops engineer
so who is a cloud devops engineer a
cloud devops engineer often referred to
as a devops engineer focusing on cloud
Technologies is a specialized IT
professional who combines devops
practices with expertise in managing and
optimizing cloud-based infrastructure
and services this rule is crucial in
ensuring that applications and systems
run efficiently and reliably in Cloud
environments Cloud develops Engineers
work at the intersection of development
operations and cloud computing to
streamline software delivery automate
processes and improve system performance
in the cloud roles and responsibilities
of a cloud develops engineer include
continuous integration and continuous
delivery cicd pipeline Implement and
maintain cicd pipelines for automating
the build test and deployment processes
of applications in Cloud environments
this accelerates software release Cycles
infrastructure as code use I tools like
terraform AWS cloud formation or asure
resource manager to Define and manage
Cloud infrastructure resources
programmatically ensuring consistency
and
repeatability Cloud resource
provisioning create configure and manage
Cloud resources such as virtual machines
storages databases and networking
components using cloud provider specific
tools and apis containerization and
orchestration deploy applications and
containers for example Docker and manage
container orchestration platforms like
kubernetes to ensure scalability and
reliability monitoring and alerting
Implement Monitoring Solutions to track
system performance resource utilization
and application Health in the cloud
setup alert and automated responses to
address issues promptly so let's go
through the career path of a cloud
develops engor entry level or junior
level devops Andor in this early stage
you'll focus on learning the
fundamentals of devops practices cloud
computing and automation you'll likely
assist with building and maintaining
cicd pipelines scripting and basic
infrastructure tasks next is a devops
engineer as you gain experience you will
take on more significant
responsibilities you'll design build and
maintain cicd pipelines automate
deployment processes and manage Cloud
infrastructure senior devops and Junior
Senior devops Engineers lead more
complex projects collaborate closely
with development and operations teams
and are responsible for optimizing the
entire software delivery pipeline they
often guide and Mentor junior team
members talking about the salary of a
cloud devops engineer according to
glasso the average salary of a cloud
devops engineer is
$137,000 perom in the United States and
in India it goes around 7 lakh 84,000
rupees perom with additional cash
benefits it depends on the company you
are working for and again on your skills
now let's explore the third category
Cloud security jobs in a world filled
with digital threats these professionals
are the Protectors of our cloud-based
data the job role we have in this
category is of a cloud security analyst
a cloud security analyst is a cyber
security professional who specializes in
safeguarding cloud computing
environments from security threats
vulnerabilities and breaches these
analysts play a crucial role in ensuring
that cloud-based systems and data remain
secure compliant with regulations and
protected against cyber attacks roles
and responsibilities of a cloud security
analyst includes security monitoring
Cloud security analysts continuously
monitor Cloud systems networks and
applications for signs of unauthorized
access suspicious activities and
potential security incidents thread
detection and Analysis they use security
tools and Technologies to detect and
analyze security threats and
vulnerabilities this involves
identifying malware intrusion attempts
and anomalies in Cloud traffic incident
response incident responses when
security incidents occur Cloud security
analyst take immediate action they
investigate the incident determine the
extent of breach and Implement
remediation measures to contain and
mitigate the impact vulnerability
assessment analysts perform
vulnerability assessment ments and
penetration testing to identify
weaknesses in Cloud configurations
applications and infrastructure they
work to address these vulnerabilities
before they can be exploited Access
Control they manage user access and
permissions within the cloud environment
ensuring that users have the appropriate
level of access to resources while
preventing unauthorized access so let's
go through the career path of a cloud
security analyst entry-level Cloud
security analyst in this entry-level
role you'll focus on foundational secur
tasks such as monitoring security alerts
assisting in Access Control and
conducting basic security assessments
next up Cloud security analysis as you
gain experience you will take on more
significant responsibilities such as
analyzing security incidents conducting
vulnerability assessments and assisting
with incident response next is senior
Cloud security analyst senior Cloud
security analysts lead more complex
security projects collaborate with cross
functional teams and provide guidance on
security policies and compliance Cloud
security consultant or adviser some
professionals in this field transition
to advisory or Consulting roles where
they offer expertise to organizations
seeking to enhance their Cloud security
posture they may conduct security
assessments provide recommendation and
develop security strategies the last is
cloud security manager or director Cloud
security manager or directors take on
leadership roles within the
organizations they oversee security
teams shape the organization security
Str stry and ensure that security aligns
with business goals talking about the
salary of a cloud security analyst
according to glaso the average salary of
a cloud security analyst is
91,9 perom in the United States and in
India it goes around 855,000 rupees per
year with additional cash benefits it
depends on the company and your skills
moving on to the last segment of this
video the final segment focuses on
infrastructure and site reliability jobs
which are crucial for maintaining the
reliability availability and performance
of cloud-based systems the most
anticipated job role in this category is
that of a cloud site reliability
engineer a cloud site reliability
engineer or Sr is a specialized IT
professional who focuses on ensuring the
reliability availability and performance
of applications and services in
cloud-based invironments the role of a
cloud SRE combines aspects of
traditional side reliability engineering
with Cloud specific expertise
emphasizing the use of cloud native
Technologies and practices to achieve
High system reliability roles and
responsibilities of a cloud site
reliability engineer includes system
reliability Cloud sres are responsible
for ensuring that cloud Hostess systems
and applications remain highly reliable
and available to user they monitor
system performance diagnose and address
issues and Implement solutions to
minimize downtime infrastructure
automation the they use infrastructure
as code ISC and Cloud automation tools
to create configure and manage Cloud
resources this helps achieve consistency
and scalability while reducing manual
intervention scalability and performance
Cloud sres design and Implement
strategies for scaling applications and
services in response to changing
workloads and traffic patterns they
optimize system performance to maintain
responsiveness Incident Management when
incident occurs Cloud sres lead incident
response effort they coordinate with
cross functional teams to identify the
root cause of issues mitigate their
impact and Implement preventive measures
the last is monitoring and alerting they
set up and maintain monitoring and
alerting systems to track the health of
cloud hostage Services they configure
alerts for predefined thresholds and
respond to alerts promptly a career path
for cloud sight reliability engineer or
SRE typically involves progression
through various stages of expertise and
responsibility the first is entry-level
cloud CL SRI or entry-level Cloud side
reliability engineer at this stage
you'll focus on learning the
fundamentals of cloud infrastructure and
srre practices you may assist with
monitoring incident responses and basic
automation tasks senior Cloud Sr senior
Cloud sres lead more complex projects
collaborate closely with the development
and operation teams and provide guidance
on system design reliability and
skillability principal Cloud SRE or SRE
manager at this level you may transition
into a leadership role overseeing a team
of sres you will shape the
organization's Sr strategy optimize
processes and ensure their reliability
of critical systems director of Sr or
chief reliability officer Some Cloud SRE
professionals aspire to become leaders
at the executive level in this role you
will provide strategic direction for the
entire Sr organization aligning it with
broader business objectives the last is
SRE consultant or Cloud SRE architect
some professionals may choose to become
SRE Consultants or Architects offering
expertise to organizations seeking to
improve their SRE practices and
reliability engineering strategies
continuous learning and staying up to
date with evolving Cloud Technologies Sr
best practices and Industry Trends are
essential for career advancement in the
field of cloud site reliability
engineering talking about the salary of
a cloud site reliability engineer
according to glas Door the average
salary of a senior Cloud SRI is 154,00
000 perom in the United States and in
India it goes around 14 lakh rupees per
year with additional cash benefits it
all comes down to the company you are
working for and the skills you possess
so there you have it the four main
categories of cloud computing jobs based
on your job descriptions whether you are
interested in AWS Azure gcp devop
security or infrastructure or site
reliability there's a rewarding career
waiting for you in the field of cloud
computing and if you still have any
doubts regarding this video then feel
free to put them down in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will definitely help you as soon as
possible so thank you so much for being
here today we'll see you next time until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
Simply learn for more updates staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here